I've heard you say that memes must be
subservient to jeans but also that we
must rebel against no jeans wouldn't
rebelling against our jeans be a set of
memes help me reconcile the
contradiction well no I think your
question reveals that you get the
problem it's not a simple one we are
wired such that our cultural nature is
subservient to our genetic nature but if
you can hear this podcast you can also
hear me say if you knew what your genes
were willing to do in the service of
spreading them you'd throw up right no
it's absolutely despicable some of what
they want now some of what they want you
to do is absolutely beautiful right but
to choose that part of what your genes
want you to do that is honorable and
decent and fits who you claim to be and
to reject that part that is despicable
and destructive and not who you want to
be that's the sweet spot so you're
already in rebellion right now the
question is not can your vow of course
you can repeal the question is can you
rebel without providing an advantage to
those who don't rebel those who will do
everything their genes want them to do
that's the deep question I don't think
anybody knows for sure what the answer
to that question is I can tell you that
I don't know of any reason that that is
impossible but I do not think it is a
simple process we have to figure out how
it is that we rebel against the portion
of what our genes want us to do that
does not fit our understanding of
ourselves without providing advantage to
those who refuse to join us in that
process and as far as I see either we
figure that out or we're cooked
[Music]